madame la Première ministre cette
question vous est adressée car elle
concerne plusieurs membres de votre
gouvernement et je vois qui a été choisi
pour me répondre quelqu'un qui n'a pas
assisté au débat dont il va être
question un de nos illustres
prédécesseurs sur ses bancs a dit que la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface alors ma question va être en
deux temps tout d'abord la forme comment
pouvez-vous
oser redéposer par l'intermédiaire d'un
49-3 une disposition qui a été rejetée
par les deux assemblées une première
fois à l'Assemblée nationale une
deuxième fois au Sénat et cette
disposition d'ailleurs a été déposée en
catimini car elle ne figurerait pas dans
les amendements retenus dans la première
version du texte et on l'a vu arriver
dans le texte consolidé envoyé le jeudi
matin aux assemblées je parle là des
contrats de confiance au contrat de
Cahors et donc j'en arrive maintenant à
ma question sur le fond madame la
Première ministre cette disposition
vatale être remise une fois que le Sénat
leur a supprimé lors de l'étude de la du
PLF pour 2023 dans le 49-3 qui sera de
nouveau déposé à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]